dan do you think that you have a lot of
anger tons I know why because the [ __ ]
like that cuz a [ __ ] damn because of
people like Dan that exist no I'm the
same way as you I but you know what it
is I do handle it better than you have a
cuter face when you smile it's okay no
but I marry all the two people think I'm
angry or even when I'm not that mad I'm
not mad right now you could know Mike
mine comes out in ways that are
detrimental to other people though like
if you harm me
yeah right I'll do something like
passive aggressive yet well like like
like you know if I run into somebody
that's harm me and I'll go hey and hug
them and go great set and then like a
week or a year later I'll do something
behind their back that affects them
you're like a lady that's like what a
lady does I behave like a lady something
that's like a lady move that I could
hold it in for years yeah no poison for
some I I let it go I say I say it fast
and I let it go the same way you say
fast let it go I have to I can't help
myself when he does something that
pisses you off it will be immediate
oh it's always that I know when she does
something to pisses you off I've held
fifty things are you banking them for
yeah I have a big for her there's a
gigantic room do you bank anything for
him no nothing let it go but her bank oh
this is the biggest World Bank like
first like some people like you your
bank is small there's two things two
things that you could do it'll explode
like the fester my sister is a buddy who
is very who internalizes a lot and every
three years she has like a massive
emotional meltdown and I never want to
get to be I never want to be like her
she has like an emotional breakdown
because she's so sit like she just holds
a lot of and I see it and she's just
always on the verge and I never would it
be like that so you just let it all go
I have to I say it to mines to a fault
though to I say it I'll say I'll say it
fast I said something so mean to my wife
before I left
oh would you say I mean I was being mean
or just that very mean you said
something mean I said something mean
what is it I don't want to say it I said
something mean okay
I said she was a fat piece of dog [ __ ]
no I just got mad because I am I am a
I'm this guy this is this is me this is
literally me right
you're her ask me you've just walked in
and say hey did you end up asking your
mom about that Christmas ornament thing
we needed okay
this and I'm watching it you might be
less complicated that's it and I'm
watching and I'm watching you use big
line babe YouTube video watching YouTube
video I hope you get it right on the
couch okay action yeah go okay roll
cameras and action hey babe did you ask
your mom about that Christmas ornament
thing that we needed what what what that
Christmas ornament thing babe what what
what is it that's what I do right away
that would I not do that the other night
with the cougar which cougar in Red Dead
Redemption oh yeah yeah I guess so so
that's my problem I snap okay you see me
on the goddamn [ __ ] yeah I'm gonna tell
you something what happened the other
night I lost my [ __ ] okay I'll tell you
something I want to know what you said
yeah besides just not being in that way
oh my god wait one more time well for
people that are out audio okay so I
don't have any patients I have no
patience when I'm on the when I'm on the
phone I'm doing a thing just let me
finish the thing as soon as I'm done
I'll get right back to you I promise but
she does it and she know she does it and
then I just I lose it yes I am a [ __ ]
[ __ ]
and you know what gets me even more mad
I imagine our neighbors are going that
guy's a [ __ ] [ __ ] cuz they never
hear her right I just hear me yelling
and I've never hit her never never never
yet you thought about it though
so I'm playing I'm playing Red Dead
Redemption
yeah video game the new one the new one
yeah it's so good huh so one of the
little goals is to kill five Cougars not
easy with a bow and arrow
finding a cougar is like running into in
real life and Eskimo sure let me ask you
something how many Eskimos have you ran
into in your whole life
honestly zero exactly and I had to kill
five of them you have to find them in
the game and kill yeah and they're very
rare yeah right yeah I finally have what
I've been looking for three hours
got one high pull back on my bow and
arrow right it's already here sweetie
I turn like this and I go back to the
screen my neck the Cougar eyes roll back
and I fall to the ground and I die and I
look like a why I didn't cry a little
bit you were so upset like this is a 16
hour a day game yes so I don't know when
to interject did you know that the
cougar was there oh yeah but now you
know right so then right and then what
she was gonna interrupt me for was this
is what she was gonna say you know Julio
and Bojo are getting along better
we had a cat a younger cat that's her
nope no mi got one of my dogs he's
getting along better yeah and you know
what you think about it that's the
information I really needed to hear that
I'm okay so yes cat purr now they're
friends they're kissing yeah and it was
such a rare moment but I had to tell him
in that moment oh my god turn around
look at what animals yeah but then
meanwhile yeah yeah and then here's what
was worse the three hours after that
being walking around trying to [ __ ] all
that and me trying to breathe hard to
let you know yes you're me outrun it
like you know
and then at 5:00 in the morning I found
one but it was not pristine coat but
still I got the thing by one of the
count you might make a jacket but
anyways pristine Co ooo the level of the
coolant level of the Cougar has to be
the right level to get the right trigger
right the right cone a cone yeah yeah
but anyway so I get what you're saying
you know what's really you know what's
really interesting about about the video
game thing what is that you play games
like Red Dead Redemption yeah where you
don't like anything of that world if it
was real but you like it in a game
that's every game [ __ ] no yeah if um
if I'm playing Skyrim I don't want to
slay a dragon in real life yes all Asian
people are somewhat fascinated with
dragon it's a part of your culture
guys do you guys this guy yeah just say
this is Game of Thrones my culture [ __ ]
you white dude well no no no it's a part
of your home as well but those dragons
but those dragons are a little - a
little too ridiculous you guys like you
guys want to see our dragons up smaller
dicks no no they're just brightly
coloured dragons you guys like bright
colour drag ride more for celibate
celebrations right Korean culture are
the dragon right yeah it's just right
here I'm just gonna go along with this
but Koreans gotta be into dragons a
little bit no not even a little
no I don't know what are they into then
was there Singapore is Umrah lion-o we
did that you know we did that when when
the Japanese was hard tying up upside
down yeah ties up and side down and you
would do that because we try to get away
aren't they great to japonais another
great I think that my favor fun there
are fun people for we go
[Music]